well i guess i was criticized for the  right reason  um for calling dame shot in the playoffs  a bad shot  i mean i see these guys range is crazy  um  you know the ability to knock those  shots down  and i mean like you said it's not like  this it's it's a half court heave like  you know these are shots that are in  there um  you know it's it's well in their range  uh they probably can shoot it deeper i  seen it was  some of them you know damaged up both  was inching further and further back so  i don't know if that's quite my range on  a consistent basis  i'm comfortable shooting from those but  those i'm comfortable  with the clocks running down and it's  like a half court shot  at half going into a half or ending a  quarter  i can't see myself shooting those uh you  know it's  you know part of my half court office so  did you say that's no longer a bad shot  it's a great shot two thumbs up  thank